in 1987
1987 i moved back
from ohio to d.c
and
enrolled in eastern high school and did
you must not have went there when i went
there champ
[Applause]
those were tough times the way i
remember it
[Laughter]
when i had gone i i lived with my father
for three years i went to middle school
in ohio and when i got back to
washington the crack epidemic was in
full swing in in the city was largely
unrecognizable to me
i was an older kid and and and kids my
age were doing a lot of wild things that
i i didn't know the kids would do i had
never seen a kid with a pager before i
didn't know anything about selling drugs
or any of that [ __ ] all i knew was every
day when i went to eastern i didn't feel
safe
[Applause]
i'm a quiet guy
naturally i'm a shy person naturally and
i used to get my
hair cut on a
barber shop 15th street northeast
and i would go there and uh
and everyone in the bomber shop would
just snap on each other
and i'd sit in the corner and i and i'd
watch everybody and just listen to all
these jokes the guys were funny and [ __ ]
but but one day
after a few weeks of going there getting
my hair cut they they turned the jokes
on me
i called that day the barbershop
massacre
i let everybody in that barber shop up
i've been sitting in there listening to
for weeks talk about each other i knew
every inside joke about each and every
one of them and they couldn't believe i
knew this stuff i lit their asses up
[Music]
and from then on in the neighborhood
people kind of like now those guys
he's pretty funny
time magazine released an article about
bill cosby the headline said 50 funny
and filthy rich and i read that article
and it was when i was looking at his
face
before all that disgrace
then i looked and i said i could do that
i told my father and my father said
wouldn't this do it that's why i
wouldn't even know where to start and he
said well look in the phone book before
the internet if you're young
we used to have a book with phone
numbers in it
[Music]
my father found for me
the local comedy club in washington dc
i called him
[Applause]
i found out when open mic night was
and i started to go there on tuesday
nights just watch
and then one night i went on a weekend i
would i would get my money together and
i would go to this comedy club and i
would just watch these comedians and
sometimes
sometimes they would talk to me
and i told one of the comedians after a
show on that i said man i really want to
try to do this and and he said well he
said
he said if you want to be a good
comedian
you should know how to act
i said why he says you know he didn't
explain it
i said okay and i told my parents
and this is how i
came to find out
about duke ellington my mother
she said there's a place you can go
where you can learn to act right here in
washington it's a it's a high school i
said you mean i would get out of eastern
[Applause]
the school year was already in full
swing and ellington has a policy that
they don't let people just come in the
middle of the year but linda gravatt was
the head of the theater department at
the time
very graciously took a meeting with me
and my mother and
i get emotional thinking about it
anybody that went here
remember what it was first like
when you first walked through the door
it was in the afternoon and everyone was
in their arts classes and the girls had
tutus on
and everyone was weird and walking
around the hallway like you weren't sure
anyone was supposed to be and you could
hear people practicing their horns and
[ __ ] all through the hallways there was
art
bouncing off the walls the minute i
walked to the door there was a gallery
of all these children's work and these
pictures were amazing
my first thought
when i walked through that door
i'm not good enough to be here
i'm sure
miss gravatt sat me down she told me
about the school and you remember miss
gravatt she was very businesslike
but also very warm
she was intimidating but probably kind
she was a paradox
of a human being
and she gave me a date
for an audition
my mother said okay dave it's on you now
those of you who know me
no that i didn't prepare for that
audition
[Applause]
that audition was like a possession it
was just something that i was proud to
have
but as the days got closer i'm like oh
my god i got to get i got to get
something together i didn't even know
how to do an audition i'd never done it
before so i went
i said i said what do i need they said a
monologue so i looked up monologue
and i went to the library the mlk
library this huge library so i got to
find something and i found a piece
in one of those yellow script books it
was a monologue by mark twain called the
judge's spirited woman
i learned it in the night
it was not hard for me to memorize
things
the next day it was a saturday i think
and i came to the school
and they auditioned
what used to be this room the original
theater at duke ellington school of the
arts
and all the department heads
sat in here and the lights in your eyes
and there's a bunch of kids
who already go to the school who come on
saturday just to see
who might be coming
and i talked to all these kids before i
went in and these kids were nothing like
the kids at eastern they were like them
but they were different they were weird
and funny and
self-deprecating things like
this and i remember
i came out on stage
and i did my audition
and it
was
like
like
terrible
i i froze up in the beginning i started
and then i said wait a minute i'm
messing up let me start again
and i was nervous and i was scared
and and in the middle of the audition
i'm in the middle of the monologue
one of the teachers fred lease he said
fred lee she goes
okay that's enough
[Music]
i said well there's still a little more
he goes no no no no no that is enough he
said
[Applause]
and i i can't tell you like i i was
crushed
without saying his disapproval i knew
and stunk
and i was right when i walked in here i
knew i wasn't good enough
to go to the school and i thought to
myself ah [ __ ] this school that's stupid
anyway
the first year theater there's a
question
that they ask students from time to time
and it's a make-or-break question and
when we ask this question you don't know
and the question is this
they say why do you want to act
now
if you say anything like i want to be a
star you're not
you're not going to get in i didn't know
that
and i figured i already blew the
audition so i told him the truth he said
why do you want to act i don't
that's what i said
and they said well then why are you here
i said because i want to be a comedian
and some comedian told me that if i want
to be a good comedian i need to learn
how to act
teachers look at each other they go
thank you very much and i left
and i was walking down the hallway
kicking rocks
there was a kid that already went here
his name was ankle handy
and they go said hey man i listen to
them talking about you i said you did he
said you're in i said what he said
you're in
that didn't make any sense
somehow we worked it out so that it gave
me an early enrollment and i left
eastman within weeks of that
and i came to duke ellington and it was
better than i could have ever imagined
i didn't have the suspicion that most
new kids get i was an oddity a new toy
it was quirky it wasn't a snappy dress i
didn't really know what the [ __ ] was
going on because the crack epidemic
itself was new to me and they were all
refugees from the neighborhood schools
[Applause]